[Musik]
in Chabo in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
werden Glasfaserkabel verlegt der Ort
soll schnelles Internet bekommen doch
diese abzweigern der Dorfstraße sorgt
bei den Anwohnern für Erstaunen hier
kommt knapp ein Kilometer Breitband
direkt neben einem Feldweg in die Erde
die Leitung führt ins Nirgendwo der
Anschluss endet an einer Kuhweide ja das
ist vollige Quatsch Nonsens da wohnt
keine und sind nur Kühe laufen darum und
das Kabel wurde da hingelegt warum auch
immer keiner weiß es vielleicht ist die
neue Zeit so dass die Kühe unbedingt
Internet brauchen ja
Kopfschütteln einfach nur Kopfschütteln
da fragt man sich was soll das
wundert sich ein Anwohner warum auf dem
Stillen Feldweg neben seinem Haus
kräftig gebuddelt wird Ludger Westphal
fragt die Arbeiter und bekommt die
Auskunft hier soll ein Breitband für
schnelles Internet hin Ludger Westphal
ist sofort klar das muss ein Fehler sein
er informiert die Behörden und auch die
kommunale Betreibergesellschaft den
staatlich geförderten Ausbau ins Nichts
will er verhindern und habe eben dann
nur die Antwort bekommen ja aufgrund
Datenschutz kriege ich keine Auskünfte
habe dann noch mal nachgehakt aber alle
seine Mails und Initiativen laufen ins
Leere das Glasfaserkabel in Richtung
Kuhweide wird unbeirrt weiter verlegt
die Meinung des Bürgers ist egal der der
vor Ort ist und sich auskennt hat
trotzdem keine Ahnung das was der Planer
sagt zählt die Gelder sind freigegeben
und damit wird es realisiert ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste wir fragen im
Kreishaus von Parchim nach ob das neue
Kabel im Feldweg wirklich dahin gehört
der kreisräumt den Fehler ein bei der
Feinplanung habe es eine Änderung
gegeben den Tiefbauunternehmen muss nach
unserer Recherche der veraltete Plan
übergeben worden sein was erst durch die
Medien Nachfrage aufgefallen ist
dabei hätte der peinliche Fehler viel
früher bemerkt werden können wenn die
Verantwortlichen auf die Dorfbewohner
gehört hätten also es wurde darauf
aufmerksam gemacht und trotzdem wo es
nichts passiert und ja das sind alles
unsere Steuergelder wie gesagt das
verpufft und das wird so viel gemacht ne
weil sinnlosen Kram und im Grunde
genommen ist es traurig sage ich mal das
sowas überhaupt passiert sei immer ach
ja anders als die kuhweite werden manche
Häuser in Chabo nicht anders neue
Glasfasernetz angeschlossen aber
hauptsache die Kühe am Dorf Rand haben
jetzt eine Weide mit Breitbandanschluss